>>Cantor: There are certain foundational
skills like executive function,
self-regulation, that are
pre-requisites for the formation
of more complex skills, like
perseverance and self-direction.
A child can become a
productive and engaged learner
from any developmental
starting point as long
as we intentionally build those skills.
>>Catherine: Any volunteers? Go up and
do a priority list? Abdi, thank you.
>>Cantor: The most active research
right now is actually about adolescence.
There are skills that develop
uniquely in adolescence
that can't develop in earlier periods.
An example of one of those is executive
function skills, which enable us
to organize and prioritize.
By asking students to prioritize
their tasks the teacher builds
that skillset in an entire classroom.
>>Catherine: In eighth
grade there's a ton
of different deadlines
and work to manage.
So, we do the ABC priority list in order
to help them manage all
those different deadlines.
>>Abdirahman: Somebody always goes
up to start our priority list.
It helps us categorize everything
that we have and organize
from most important to least important.
>>Student: We have the West Virginia
versus Barnette case
questions for social studies.
>>Catherine: When is that due?
>>Student: Today.
>>Catherine: So, it's a high priority.
>>Student: We have a practice clot [ph?]
that we need to do for science class.
>>Abdirahman: They tell
me each assignment
and when it's due or
how important it is.
>>Student: We have the JIAS
observation for science.
>>Catherine: Oh, wow. Jeez.
>>They share out all the different
deadlines that are roaming
around in their head and
then they know how to go
through the protocol of prioritizing.
>>Catherine: Can you help Abdi
to figure out what the A1 is?
>>Student: JIAS observation?
>>Catherine: I think so, because it's
overdue, right? So, if it's overdue,
you've got to get that done first.
And then what would be in A2?
>>Student: The West Virginia
versus Barnette questions.
>>Cantor: It wasn't a
teacher saying, "You should."
It was a student saying,
"Here's what I think are the ways
in which these activities
should be prioritized."
So, in effect what this
teacher was doing was modeling
and teaching executive function skills.
>>Arius: If you're kind of overwhelmed
by your work, then you can kind
of like know what to do first and
then just kind like categorize it
and get it done efficiently.
>>Catherine: Okay, so, which one
of those things is probably
going to be your frog?
>>Catherine: Mark Twain said if you
wake up every morning and eat a frog,
everything else will taste great.
So, I taught them to take
their frog from the list,
which is the thing they want to do
the least, and get it out of the way,
because everything else will seem easy.
>>Abdirahman: Our frog is like
the most important assignment,
like the one I'm really worried about.
>>Catherine: Dry ice. So, okay, you've
got to do that. What's your frog?
>>Abdirahman: It helps me realize I
need to get this done faster than I need
to get this done, so even though
this is more fun I need to get this
out of the way before I can do this.
>>Catherine: So, as soon as we're
done with that priority list,
I notice everyone gets right to work,
because they have it spelled
out very clearly for them.
>>Cantor: This is the building of
executive function skills in kids.